four days
that is how long a celebrity was allowed
to question transgenderism before she
was forced to make a groveling apology
on tv
we all knew it was going to happen
we all knew
that the powers that be were going to
bring her to heal
and they did
the celeb
was the singer macy gray
she got in trouble as we covered last
week on piers morgan's show
and i will say this and everybody's
gonna hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact
there you go
she knew it was going to be politically
incorrect she knew it was going to be
controversial
but women are a thing
and men are not women
and macy is going to speak the truth no
matter the cost
for a few days until she wanted to make
money again
there was a wave of of backlash that
came as a result
just tell me where you are right now on
that statement
well uh i never of course meant to hurt
anybody with with what i said i'm not
i'm actually a huge uh
i think it takes a lot of courage to be
yourself to to go out in the world and
be honest about who you are
and uh so i think anyone who is
in the lgbt community is a hero and sets
an example for all of us with that you
know i think you you you can like i said
in there you can call yourself what like
you
you whoever you believe you are and no
one can dictate that for you or take
that away from you you know
i think life is an education process the
more you sit with people the more you
talk to people it changes your
perspective so has has your perspective
changed do you feel
i've learned so much and i think um
you know being a woman is a vibe and
it's something i'm i'm very proud of i
think that if you
in your heart feel that that's what you
are then that's what you are regardless
of what anybody says
or thinks you know what i'm saying okay
so um
but yeah i've i've learned a lot
absolutely and i'm glad i did well i
know well thank you for clearing that up
because i think people got confused and
people sometimes you realize that
through education you maybe you do you
feel differently about things
it's like a hostage video
did you learn
did you learn macy what what have you
learned macy about questioning the left
i try to say transgender's not real
i didn't think the point was a big deal
but then they put a gun to my head and
told me say dudes are chicks or you're
dead buy my album please buy my album
macy gray macy gray completely selling
out her deeply held belief
in just a few days obviously she didn't
have a genuine change of heart when she
was asked what changed she just
kind of rambled vaguely about learning
and education and then she rambled until
she finally landed on something that was
acceptable enough for that lib
interviewer
and how did the libs get her to do it
the same way that they get anyone to do
anything which is carrots
and sticks
hey macy you want to sell some albums
yeah you want you want some more fame
and money cool cool that's great that's
easy
just say what we want you to say and do
what we want you to do and if you do
that everything will be great and oh
yeah by the way if you don't we will
destroy your entire life
carrots
and sticks and they're not just after
late 90s pop stars that is how the libs
force their will
on everyone over whom they hold power
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
which is a vibe man you know don't you
the michael knowles show it is a vibe
macy is so right about that my favorite
comment on friday is from miles morales
who says
when the whole world is running toward a
cliff he who is running in the opposite
direction appears to have lost his mind
c.s lewis absolutely right like so many
things cs lewis said that is absolutely
right
so now when you have your head screwed
on straight and you view the world in a
correct way it kind of makes you a
target
which is why you got to check out
expressvpn right now head on over to
expressvpn.com
knowles do it right now
you go on the internet you look at
things that the powers that be don't
want you to look at no i'm not talking
about that stuff get your mind out of
the gutter i'm talking about the daily
wire i'm talking about politically
incorrect things that the sensors who
control the misinformation boards that
they don't want you to look at they've
got it out for you they don't like our
country very much they don't like our
traditional way of life okay and so you
don't want to hand those people over
your data when you go on expressvpn they
will anonymize your data they will
encrypt it i use expressvpn on all of my
devices
don't don't have to worry about your
search history the websites you're
looking at the books you're reading all
that kind of stuff you you can rest easy
knowing that the big tech sensors aren't
seeing you when you use expressvpn use
the vpn that i trust
expressvpn.com head on over there right
now get three months of expressvpn for
free e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
knowles get three months free
expressvpn.com
knowles
the the way that the libs wield power is
both it's not just all carrot and it's
not just all stick they do reward you if
you engage in politically correct woke
behavior they will promote you they will
give you positions of prestige they will
help you out in your career
it's not all just
it's it's not all just carrot though
there is obviously some stick as well
they will punish you they will cancel
you they will threaten you with violence
okay and it's not just the radical crazy
ones in the streets the antifa and the
blm people who are out there burning
down buildings it's the nice ones too
and in in some ways the nice ones are
even more insidious about it it's people
like pete butterjudge pete buddha
judge's life partner chasin bootage
came out and he was asked about brett
kavanaugh the supreme court justice
being run out of a restaurant in
washington d.c he was in morton brett
kavanaugh was in morton's steakhouse and
a bunch of libs showed up screaming
creating a whole ruckus outside and
kavanagh had to leave through the
kitchen through the back entrance and
this is after people were showing up
illegally in front of kavanaugh's house
and the houses of the other justices
this is after a lib tried to assassinate
brett kavanaugh because of the dobb's
decision and pete buddha judge's life
partner jason budajudge came out and he
basically said yeah well you get what
you get
that's what you get you overrule roe v
wade people are going to show up and
scream and intimidate you
pete was asked about his pal's behavior
on television and pete basically said
the same thing
your husband tweeted after
justice brett kavanaugh left a
washington restaurant due to protesters
the tweet reads sounds like he just
wanted some privacy to make his own
dining decisions
is that appropriate sir
look when
public officials go into public life we
should expect two things one
you should always be free from violence
harassment and intimidation and two
you're never going to be free from
criticism or peaceful protest people
exercising their first amendment rights
and that's what happened in this case
remember the justice never even came
into contact with these protesters
reportedly didn't see or hear them
and these protesters are upset because a
right an important right that the
majority of americans support was taken
away not only the right to choose by the
way but but this justice was part of the
process of stripping away the right to
privacy as long as i've been alive
settled case law in the united states
has been that the constitution protected
a right to privacy and that has now been
thrown out the window by justices
including justice kavanaugh so much is
wrong with buddha judge's statement i
love how he says as long as i've been
alive yeah you're 12 years old pete so
sure you've been alive for five minutes
and during that time we've had this
ridiculous idea of a right to privacy
which does not exist it's not in the
constitution look with a big uh
microscope it's not it's not going to
appear there uh you can you can look
with the magnifying lens it's not you
try to find the emanations and the
numbers in the invisible link there is
no general right to privacy in the
constitution furthermore the dobbs
decision did not do anything about the
so-called right to privacy when we're
talking about the other decisions that
the quote unquote right to privacy would
uh would
have some pertinence to we're talking
about contraception we're talking about
homosexual sodomy we're talking about
the redefinition of marriage the supreme
court decision in dobbs specifically
said we're not touching those decisions
so all of that is a lie and all of that
is a lie to distract from and paper over
the fact
that pete buddha judge's partner said uh
yeah kavanaugh deal with it you're gonna
do it just just like chuck schumer said
we're coming for you brett kavanaugh
just like the mobs that have been
showing up outside of kavanaugh's house
have been saying and what does buddha
judge say he says well yeah um f around
and find out
yeah uh you get what you get and you
can't get upset
that's right we're coming for you brett
kavanaugh
why would brett kavanaugh be worried
about mob's show it's not as if a
leftist tried to assassinate him just
three weeks ago
oh wait it's exactly like that it's
exactly like that and what was the joke
that that buddha judge's pal was making
the joke is
that
the
uh the right to go eat in a restaurant
is just like the right to go
kill your child through abortion
well maybe kavanaugh should have kept
his mouth closed maybe kavanaugh
shouldn't have walked into that
restaurant i saw other left-wing blue
checkmarks making the same joke
and i i don't really get it
there there i understand they're trying
to compare going to a restaurant to
killing your child through abortion but
what's the comparison you have a right
to go to a restaurant you have a right
to eat food you don't have a right to
kill your baby
so what's the i don't really get what
the joke is regardless of the the libs
attempts at humor here
the the important lesson is
it's not just the angry ones
it's not just the purple hairs with the
crazy tattoos and piercings and
mutilations that are screaming in
people's faces it's the nice ones too
it's the entire liberal apparatus is
wielding a a system of sticks and
carrots
to get you to comply
and they'll make macy gray comply
she stated her obviously deeply held
view that men are not women and then
four days and all that's all it took was
four days and she got back in line she
wants to make a little more money and
she doesn't want to have her life ruined
and they're going to try to bring
everyone in line they're going to try to
bring supreme court justices in line
they're going to try to bring members of
congress in line they're going to try
most especially to bring you in line
that's what it's really all about it's
like that meme that trump posted during
the 2020 election it's a picture of him
and it said they're not after me they're
after you i just happen to be in the way
that's what this is really all about
it's not about hollywood or washington
dc or new york it's about you americans
and how they are going to wield
incentives and punishments to get you to
shut up and comply don't do that don't
play their game you don't even need to
go on their social media platforms when
you can go check out tuvu right now head
on over to tuvu.com
knowles we are facing a mental health
crisis it is directly linked to big tech
social media platforms we all love
social media we're all on social media
that's how we live today that's the
public square
problem is these platforms are designed
to addict you to likes the affirmation
of others they are not good for us for
our minds or for our spirits they're
funded by advertising that for the first
time in history is tailored specifically
and individually for you what's the goal
the goal is to cater to your every whim
whether those whims are edifying or
destructive every whim that they think
will make you give them more of your
time and money thankfully there is a new
social media app that breaks the mold of
the advertising based model designed
with your best interests in mind and
based on connection not addiction that
is tuvu the social app where you can
share what matters to you by offering a
membership-based platform built on
family values and freedom toovu makes it
possible for you to have a guilt-free
social media experience have you been
looking for a social media platform that
will allow you to get back to basics you
just want to share pictures of your
family and your friends and maybe the
occasional meme without all that toxic
sludge that comes on the other platforms
well head on over to tuvu
it's super super simple to sign up you
download tuvu you try it free for seven
days then it's just 299 a month it's not
a lot of money it's a little bit of
money and when you think about those
free quote unquote social media
platforms they ain't so free they're
costing money in other ways go to
tuvu.com
knowles or look for the tuvu app on
google play or the app store and
remember to follow me at michael j
knowles
when the libs are not threatening you to
bring you in line they're just lying and
and it's not the propagandists on msnbc
alone it's not the people on cnn alone
it's all the way up to the president of
the united states who spent the weekend
peddling a a really heart-wrenching
story really it's about as
heart-wrenching a story as you can
possibly imagine about a ten-year-old
girl who i was raped i guess and and she
she went to her doctor and the doctor
said you can't have an abortion and then
the girl i don't know she had to flee to
indiana or something like that uh the
problem with the story of course
there's no evidence for it
some of the states don't allow for
exceptions for rape or incest
this isn't some imagined horror
it's already happening
just last week it was reported that a 10
year-old girl
was a rape victim in height 10 years old
and she was forced to have to travel out
of the state to indiana
to seek to terminate the presidency and
maybe save her life that's last part is
my judgment
10 years old
10 years old
raped six weeks pregnant
already traumatized was forced to travel
to another state
imagine being that little girl
just i'm serious just imagine being that
little girl 10 years old
does anyone believe that it's ohio's
majority view that that should not be
able to be dealt with
so this story is just completely fake
usually when these stories come out and
there's not
a ton of evidence i'll try to hedge my
bets here and if i'm giving analysis
i'll say well there's not a ton of
evidence but maybe and this one i'm just
gonna say it's totally fake it's just
completely made up here's how i know
that the story as joe biden is telling
it is not real
joe biden says
that
this girl became pregnant at 10 years
old the odds of becoming pregnant at 10
years old are extremely low the odds of
having your first period and even being
biologically
possibly able to become pregnant at 10
years old are extremely low the average
age of a girl getting her first period
is 12 and a half 8 percent or fewer than
8 percent of girls will get their their
first period by 10. so the odds of and
by the way it's not as though you get
your first period and then you instantly
can become pregnant the the odds of this
happening are extremely extremely low
but it's possible right
eight percent or less okay but there's
still a possibility there but then he
says she needed an abortion to save her
life
right this is not an elective abortion
because obviously getting an abortion is
not going to
undo the fact that this girl allegedly
was raped
it's not going to it's not going to
change the past it's not going to it's
only going to add another crime a
horrible crime on top of a horrible
crime that's already taken place
but he says no it's to save her life
but
we know that's not true because in ohio
there are exceptions to save a woman's
life to the pro-life law
so it wouldn't be true even if the story
did have a basis in reality that the
girl had to travel to indiana
furthermore he says it has been reported
in the news okay well where has it been
reported this was reported
in the indianapolis star by one single
source the the single source is an ob
gyn named dr caitlin bernard dr caitlin
bernard is a radical pro-abortion
activist what was caitlyn bernard's
evidence did she say i had this girl
come to me and beg for an abortion no it
wasn't even that kind of first-hand
experience she said that she received a
phone call
from a child abuse doctor in ohio who
told her
that he had seen this patient who was a
ten-year-old who wanted to have an
abortion or presumably whose parents or
abuser or rapist wanted to get her an
abortion to cover up the crime
then that was it no further information
was given so some other newspapers that
were a little more responsible than the
indianapolis star or joe biden tried to
come out and and verify the information
they couldn't do it at all the name of
the alleged child abuse doctor
not known the city or county where this
rape allegedly happened no one's willing
to say there's no confirmation at all
you could you could check it with law
enforcement records to say well
at least can we know that this rape
happened nope there's no no evidence of
that whatsoever snopes which is a
left-wing website tried to contact this
doctor caitlyn bernard after the story
went viral the doctor refused to respond
and then the outlet uh
pointed out they were unable
independently to corroborate the
abortion claim even the washington post
even the washington post which is pravda
on the potomac and extremely lib paper
they say bottom line here this is a very
difficult story to check bernard is on
the record but obtaining documents or
other confirmation is all but impossible
without details that would identify the
locality where the rape occurred and the
people who were peddling the story
refused to disclose any of that so
not happening they're obvious they're
not the libs are not after the the
alleged rapist of this alleged girl
there's no evidence that any of these
people even exist beyond the radical
doctor by the way the radical doctor has
been speaking to many media outlets to
promote her pro-abortion stance and she
even spoke to media outlets after she
allegedly received the call from the
child abuse doctor but then she didn't
come up with her story about this rape
of a ten-year-old girl until a few days
later so it's just it's just completely
bogus okay it's totally fake and the
reason that the libs are peddling this
is the same reason that the libs are
are focused on calling miscarriages
abortions right right the libs are
saying we need to have abortion legal in
america because if a woman has a
miscarriage she needs to be able to
receive care well she doesn't need an
abortion if you have a miscarriage by
definition
treatment for that would not be an
abortion abortion only deals with a
living baby it's the exact same reason
that the libs and the dobbs decision
didn't really talk about abortion and
didn't really talk about roe v wade they
only talked about gay marriage they
focused on contraception they talked
they focused on lawrencev texas and
homosexual sodomy they did it because
they know they don't have a leg to stand
on when it comes to abortion or roe v
wade or planned parenthood to be casey
and so they've just got to distract and
make it up
they are so
desperate to defend abortion that the
libs are really shooting themselves in
the foot
it's a this is my favorite version of it
a woman
this is being reported in the dallas
morning news
a pregnant woman
says her fetus should count as a
passenger in hov lanes
she got a ticket anyway when she got
pulled over they say the the overturning
of roe v wade
has one driver questioning hov lane laws
requiring two passengers in a car yeah
take that conservatives take that
conservative you think
you think that a baby is really a baby
well if that's the case then maybe
pregnant women should be allowed to
drive in the carpool lane you know the
corporal lanes that we libs invented and
that are really a nuisance and mess up
traffic and we invented them because
we're worried about global warming which
you conservatives don't really care
about at all and probably don't believe
in you know that so we're gonna what are
you saying what the libs are saying is
that in order to try to own the cons
when it comes to abortion they're going
to
effectively abolish carpool lanes right
because if
if if a pregnant woman can ride in the
carpool lane then really any woman could
plausibly drive in the carpool lane
because any woman could say that she's
pregnant and it's just not showing yet
so they're willing to abolish the stupid
hov lanes which conservatives already
don't like
in order to
try to point out some hypocrisy or
something on abortion no i think it's
great i think pregnant women absolutely
should drive in the carpool lane
i think all women should drive in the
carpool lane
i think everybody should drive in the
carpool lane this is the same sort of
thing you see when the libs will say oh
yeah you think that a baby is a human
being well maybe we should pass laws
requiring men who impregnate women
to take care of them from the moment of
conception
great sounds good cool serious we should
make it harder
for men and women to break up when they
have a kid together we should we should
encourage marriage is what you're saying
and discourage divorce
and encourage people to have
ever more normal family structures cool
sounds good
i'm in sign me up
well
if you think that a baby
is really a baby maybe we should support
giving special tax benefits i actually
saw this there was a prominent liberal
account on twitter last night who said
we should give we should give
tax benefits to
pregnant women
and and men you know in families who who
have a baby on the way
uh we should allow those those people to
count the baby in the womb as a
dependent
oh no
please don't you're telling me we have
to defend life and you're going to cut
specifically my taxes oh no you know
conservatives who we famously hate tax
cuts
right so the limbs are trying anything
and they're throwing spaghetti at the
wall here and they keep getting more and
more frustrated because all of the
all of the proposals that they're making
to try to show our hypocrisy are
proposals that we actually like and it
shows you something that we've pointed
out on the show a lot a lot in the past
which is
conservatives basically understand what
the libs believe the libs really have no
idea what conservatives believe and you
see this nowhere more clearly than on
pro-life on the issue of life the libs
truly believe that pro-lifers just we
hate women we don't really care about
babies we don't really think the baby in
the womb is a baby but we just hate
women and we want to control their
bodies and that's not it's just not true
i know that they believe that but it's
just not true and so all of their
attempts to refute our arguments and own
us and and dismantle our political
program all it's ever going to do is
shoot them in the foot they are smacking
their own nose despite their face and
they're bolstering the pro-life side
works for me i'm feeling much more
comfortable these days another reason i
feel comfortable x chair right now go to
externals.com and let me give you a back
massage i will not be using my hands
personally but i will be using x chair i
am introducing you to x chair and you
are so so very lucky many of us spend
more time every day in our office chair
than in our cars or our beds which is
why it is so important to invest in the
right chair to spend those hours with
the right level of support and comfort
to get the most productivity out of your
day x chair has made my time here at the
office so much better and more
productive it is the best my only
complaint about xchair is when my ex
share arrived these jackals at the
office my colleagues these hyenas all
tried to steal my x-chair okay
exterior's patented dynamic variable
lumbar dvl offers the ultimate
customized support also x-chair can give
you a massage can heat you up can cool
you down right now thanks to exterior's
new fs360 armrests you can even adjust
the armrests to the perfect position
absolutely fabulous fabulous
product right now there's a sale through
july 15th buy now to beat the price
increase go to externals.com
letter x chair know
wlas.com or call
1-844-4x chair that is x share they've
got a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month
externals.com
with the price of
everything skyrocketing there has never
been a better time to get your finances
in order yesterday our pal ben shapiro
released a brand new episode of sunday
special that just might help it's
available now at dailywireplus.com
this features a very special guest
best-selling author of rich dad poor dad
robert kiyosaki and with the perfect
storm of inflation and recession and an
educational system that is turning young
people against the value of free markets
robert has something new to say his book
the capitalist manifesto is a direct
response to these current times in this
episode of sunday special robert tells
us how he discovered capitalism growing
up explains the difference between good
and bad debt and how the biden
administration compares to that of his
longtime friend and collaborator former
president donald trump speaking of great
value when you become a daily wire plus
member you also get access to our
extensive content library become a
member at
dailywireplus.com check out the latest
episode of sunday special that is
dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
a woke lady soldier in the u.s army is
questioning her loyalty to america
in the wake of the dobb's decision
overruling roe v wade
it happened
it happened
i woke up from a nap to this
on deployment i woke up from a nap to
this news
america is waking up to this news
i just extended my contract
to continue serving this country a week
ago
how am i supposed to swear to support
and defend
the constitution
and a country
that treats its women like second-class
citizens
how am i supposed to do that how am i
supposed to do that with pride
how am i supposed to do that with love
and honor
how am i supposed to wake up every day
and put on a freaking uniform that says
united states army when the united
states doesn't even give a rat's ass
about me
i don't know guess you gotta leave
i love this woman is threatening she's
implicitly threatening to leave the army
i'm not how am i supposed to serve
howard
how are you to expect us liberal woke
women to serve in the army conservatives
oh i guess we can't bye
guess you have to leave then
is that a threat or a promise darling
don't threaten me with a good time get
out we don't want you in the army we
don't i don't the woman is questioning
her loyalty to america well while
wearing or she's not wearing in that
video i guess she's got it in her closet
or something
a u.s army uniform don't don't do me any
favors get out i don't want you in the
army
that's fine the kicker of course is
she's posting her treasonous nonsense on
tick tock on a chinese spy app get out
of the army we don't want you there go
away
she should be fired of course
it's not just that she should be
permitted to quit if you
question your loyalty to the united
states of america
over killing babies or for any other
reason
over america not letting you kill enough
babies or for any other reason and you
do so on a chinese spy app
get out you should be fired she should
probably be court-martialed she should
at the very least be let go go into
private life go away go away please
this is another example of of the libs
not getting what we want
conservatives fought women in combat
positions we didn't fight the women we
fought putting women in combat positions
because it's extremely disordered and
it's not good for a country to do that
and because the army is not about our
individual rights the army is about
protecting the country and sometimes we
have to
to to suppress our own individual
desires for the greater good of
protecting the country which is the
whole point of the army we fought that
and until very very recently
conservatives still don't like the idea
and now this liberal woman is saying
yeah no i'm well maybe i'll leave the
army good oh no
this is just like the car lane thing or
the liberals
encouraging marriage as a response to to
the overruling of roe v wade or
encouraging chastity or encouraging any
of these things they think we're gonna
we're gonna protest that we're gonna
fight back we're not gonna fight back
that's what we want get out compare this
lady by the way
to a retired
general retired three i think he's a
three-star general retired lieutenant
general gary valesky
who was serving as a highly qualified
expert senior mentor he was just
suspended
from the military and he was suspended
from the military
for posting a
generally
polite
really innocuous kind of joking tweet to
jill biden jill biden tweeted out also
on this roe v wade issue said for nearly
50 years women have had the right to
make our own decisions about our bodies
today that right was stolen from us so
it's joe biden whining about how
american women can't kill quite as many
babies anymore and
this general didn't even have a
political dispute with her and he didn't
say anything insulting he just responded
and said glad to see you finally know
what a woman is
because the lives have been saying for
years we don't know what a woman is what
is a woman matt made his whole movie
about it and then the minute that roe v
wade gets overruled all of a sudden they
figure out what a woman is and then the
general actually deleted the tweet
doesn't matter he's been suspended from
the military
for for making a lighthearted joke
about the political controversy
surrounding the very definition of the
word woman meanwhile this woke chickie
in the army gets to say i might not be
loyal to america anymore and she gets to
keep her job does that make any sense
no
no it doesn't make any sense until you
realize
that there are two tracks of justice
here
there are two tracks of justice there's
justice
there's justice injustice really in both
tracks but there's going to be one
system of punishment for conservatives
who transgress liberal orthodoxy
and there's going to be another track
for the liberals and it's not going to
be punishment very often it's going to
be a reward if if i went out into the
street right now and started punching
people and stealing nike shoes out of
storefronts and tossing molotov
cocktails i would be thrown in prison
for a very very long time
if blm goes out and does the same thing
kamala harris will bail them out of jail
they will get a slap on the wrist if
that they'll probably have their charges
dismissed so that they're ready to go
back out in the streets and commit acts
of terror for the next left-wing cause
du jour
that's what it's really about so the
woke lady goes out and whines and
screams and says i might not be loyal to
my country i
doubt she'll be punished
and yet this general makes a joke
lightly questioning transgenderism he's
going to be suspended his career is
totally over
nowhere is this clearer than with hunter
biden
if you or i did
one
ten thousandth
of what hunter biden has done if we
committed 110 000 of the crimes hunter
biden has committed we would all be in
prison for a very we'd lose our money
we'd lose our house we'd lose our
reputation we'd be in prison for a long
time hunter biden gets to go into the
white house gets to do whatever he wants
and we know that more and more of this
each day
4chan now this according to uh jack
pacobic has reported this 4chan has
cracked hunter biden's iphone backup
password
and is now leaking everything
i'm always skeptical of leaks
because you never know if the
information is accurate or not in this
case we have videos of hunter pictures
of hunter
and
it makes his laptop look wholesome
actually i saw the link i click on it i
just wanted to see if there was anything
politically relevant there and then
immediately what you get is just
pictures and videos of naked hunter
biden i've probably seen that guy naked
more than i've seen any other human
being naked at this point including
myself in the mirror when i'm taking a
shower it's just so i had i just said
okay all right enough i don't need don't
need to see any more of this i get it
it's a lot of crack it's a lot of
hookers it's a lot of
and it's a more importantly it's a lot
of financial crimes it's a lot of
corruption it's a lot of selling
american influence a lot of it
implicates
joe biden
when it this is a little bit of an
unpopular take when it comes to hunter
biden
the more of his stuff that i saw
the sorry or i feel for him
i do i genuinely i told you i feel sorry
for some people when they're victims of
bad people
but i feel sorry for for most bad people
too i feel i feel sorry for criminals in
that they are not only hurting other
people they are hurting themselves
and this is an idea that goes all the
way back to ancient greece and old uncle
socrates
hunter biden is just
such a degenerate his life is terrible
he has completely destroyed his life
he's just
such a sad sorry sack of a degenerate
and i do have this thought
there but for the grace of god
go all of us
what do you mean hunter biden was raised
with all sorts of privileges right
that's kind of the problem
more of the messed up people that i know
are rich kids than poor kids poor kids i
i know messed up poor kids too but i
would say a higher percentage of them
messed up debauched decadent they got
drug problems they got all sorts of
problems people that i know
grew up rich not poor
that that can come with all sorts of
problems plus the guy had kind of a bad
life his mom died when he was really
really young his dad is just an empty
suit
power hungry simpering politician who
who
has pursued his his backslapping career
in washington the whole time
and his
they engaged in all sorts of corruption
and so i do i actually i sort of feel
bad for the guy
i don't just want to make fun of all the
crack and the hookers and the
guns and the crime and when it comes to
hunter
all i care about when it comes to hunter
is what it means for joe
because i don't think it was just hunter
doing this stuff on his own joe biden
was very involved in this kind of stuff
and you see it more and more it's coming
out there's this weird story that
apparently
joe biden was in hunter's phone as pedo
peter
joe biden sometimes
famous people will use pseudonyms in
their personal communications in case
they get hacked and just just for
privacy and so they'll pick random names
you know mitt romney had this burner
twitter account called pierre delecto
and apparently joe bidens was peter
henderson or something like that and
that's what he would use in emails with
his family and so hunter had him in his
phone as pedo peter
that's a little bit weird
you
you know that
joe biden was involved in hunter's
business dealings even though he said
that he wasn't we now know this because
we have a voicemail from the
laptop and cellphone from hell we have a
voicemail from joe biden
talking about hunter's business dealings
why is there a voicemail of the
president
talking to his son about his overseas
business dealings if the president has
said
he's never spoken to his son about his
overseas business
well first i'll say that
what the president said stands so
if he if that's what the president said
that that is what stands and second
secondly
secondly
secondly business dealings and he says i
think you're clear
how is that not him talking to his son
about his overseas business dealings
we're not from this podium i am not
going to talk about alleged materials
from the laptop
i am not going to talk about alleged
materials on the laptop is not happening
then that it is not peter i refer you to
uh to his son's representative
you didn't hear what you heard
that's the answer from the white house
joe biden had said i have never not once
not ever
spoken to my son about his business
dealings now we knew this was a lie
we knew this was a lie because hunter
admitted it was a lie in an interview
years ago hunter said yeah my dad when
he found out about all my corrupt
business dealings overseas he said you
better know what you're doing
and then he said oh oops i mean no we
didn't have a conversation never mind
so we already knew we heard it from the
horse's mouth
we already knew joe biden was lying but
now we know with 100 certainty because
we can hear it in joe biden's voice on
his son's cell phone because his
degenerate crackhead son
kept leaving all of his technology all
over the place for everyone to find and
he recorded every damn thing in his
entire life
so we now heard joe biden talking to his
son about his son's extremely corrupt
overseas business dealings which
according to the hunter laptop
involved kickbacks for joe biden
and carina jean-pierre the white house
press secretary says
whatever the president said
is true
no
if there is a disagreement between what
you heard with your own ears
and what the president said the
president is
two plus correct
does equal five
oceania has always been at war with east
asia
corn pop always was a bad dude come on
man come on man
they're ju it's just pure gaslighting so
how do they get away with this it's it
requires a lot of hubris and it requires
a hubris
that that holds that
they are not accountable to anyone
you would think that they would feel
some accountability toward the voters
but they don't
they don't feel accountability toward
the voters or to anybody else because
joe biden he won the most votes than
ever in all of the history of democracy
he won 70 bazillion
votes
and so he's not worried at all even
though he's underwater now on all of his
approval ratings on every single issue
they're not going to change course
they're not going to answer anything
they are not accountable
to anyone and and
i don't i don't care for joe biden to
answer about his kids drug use i feel
bad i feel bad for that it's bad it's
bad to have a kid who's in trouble and
who's a degenerate and that's i i don't
think he should answer for that or even
for the hookers or even for but
joe biden certainly needs to answer
for his role
in the corrupt business dealings the
multiple times that he's met with
hunter's business partners
while they were
well joe biden was in office and while
hunter was concluding this business or
in conducting this business he certainly
needs to answer that and what the white
house says is la la la la la you can
keep asking i don't care i don't owe you
any answer at all
you want to look at this kind of
corruption joe biden right now is suing
arizona
he's suing arizona because arizona is is
passing a law
that says that you need to prove that
you are a citizen in order to vote
and biden is suing the only reason
that you would sue a state
over a citizenship proof of citizenship
requirement
is if your electoral strategy involves
getting illegal votes
that's the only reason
we're talking about arizona here okay
we're not talking about
idaho
we're not talking about montana
where illegal immigration is is not much
of an issue we're talking about arizona
if not ground zero then pretty close for
the illegal immigration problem in
america there are lots and lots and lots
of illegal
aliens in that place so
you arizona passes this law they say
okay we're not unfortunately the federal
government's not dealing with the
illegal immigration problem well at the
very least we want to protect our
democracy you know our democracy that
the libs supposedly hold so sacred we're
going to protect that by passing a law
that says you have to prove that you're
a citizen and biden says nope
we're not cheating we're not cheating in
the election we never steal elections we
never rig elections and if you try to
stop us from rigging them we're going to
sue you into the dirt
we're not this is our strategy and if
you tell us what our strategy is we're
going to call you a liar and say you you
spread fake news it's such
hubris
the part that's i think most offensive
to people is that they don't even feel
the obligation to try to make it make
sense to try to spin it
pete buddha judge is probably my least
favorite member of the entire
administration because he's so glib and
was just created in a petri dish at
langley but
give pete buda judge credit at least
when he is
trying to deceive the american people he
tries to spin a yarn you try he just
tries to make it sound and listen in our
democracy it's really important to
harass supreme court justices wherever
they go and the reason we have to do
that is because right and it's it's
disingenuous and it's glib but it's
smarmy but he's trying hypocrisy is the
is the tribute that vice pays to virtue
the rest of the biden administration
biden in particular his spokesman the
doj
they're not even trying that they're
saying yeah uh whatever too bad what are
you gonna do about it
speaking of democrats and illegal travel
by the way
it's a great story it came out last week
about the possible democrat nominee in
2024 who might not be joe biden and i
really wanted to get to it so california
is really upset that some other states
are not going to let people kill babies
anymore or they're going to make it a
little bit harder to kill babies and so
gavin newsom has grandstanded on this
issue and said well for states that
won't let you kill your baby through
abortion we are not going to fund state
travel
to those states
i bet they would fund state travel to
parts of africa they would probably fund
state travel to the middle east they
would probably fund state travel to all
sorts of places with problematic laws
but they say we're not going to fund
travel to conservative states pro-life
states
but then gavin newsom violates his own
rules gavin newsom just got caught on
vacation in montana he obviously knew
that this was going to be a little
politically incorrect because his office
refused to disclose where he was going
usually newsom says where he goes on
vacation he didn't say he was going to
montana because montana is one of the 22
states to which california bans state
funded travel due to all sorts of
policies not even the just the pro-life
policies but
anti-lgbtq policies any sort of policy
that contradicts the orthodoxies of the
left so that and they don't even really
have the abortion ban yet but they're
likely to institute the abortion ban and
so newsome gets caught
and he keeps not
caring this is my favorite part about
newsome
is newsom just he
he institutes the kovid lockdown and
then he immediately breaks it and then
he gets caught breaking it and he issues
this kind of teary-eyed apology and then
he what does he do he goes and breaks it
again he just the guy can't win for
losing he gets caught in the french
laundry eating indoors with all of his
pals and none of them have masks on but
he's forcing all of the little hoi
polloi to put the masks on then he bans
state travel to all of these terrible
red states or even purple states and
then what does he do he immediately goes
to those states and he just he just
believes the rules don't apply to him
he's like hunter biden with a little
more personal discipline a little bit
more personal discipline
and a little more of that american
psycho look to him but it's the same
thing he just says the rules are not
going to apply to me there's one set of
rules for everyone else there's one set
of rules for me and he's right they're
probably not going to apply to him it's
especially funny with gavin newsom
because newsome might be the 2024
if joe biden can run in 2024 i bet he
will that guy likes being president he
likes having the power he likes being
the guy he's wanted to be president
since he was two years old
so if he can run at 82 or however old
he's going to be he will if he can't
who's the nominee going to be kamala
harris i don't think so she's less
likeable than biden pete bootage i don't
think so he's trying really hard i don't
think it's going to happen elizabeth
warren no she's over liawatha's time has
passed
so who
klobuchar
may maybe i don't uh
newsom actually
looks relatively good in the democrat
field though i am damning with faint
praise and he's really setting the stage
for his run
by behaving just like all the other
ruling class democrats do
and behaving with total hypocrisy as
though the rules don't apply to them
and then they just lie and lying loud
i'll leave you with a line from karine
jean-pierre
she was asked about
the economy obviously gas prices through
the roof cost of everything through the
roof inflation terrible poised to enter
into a recession and what does she say
she doesn't even just say hey it's going
to get better hey we're working on it
hey we're trying hey we're doing our
best she says
we are stronger economically
than we have ever been
because because when you look at
inflation when we look at where we are
economically and we are in a strong
we are a stronger economically than we
have been uh in history when you look at
the unemployment numbers at 3.6
uh when you look at the jobs numbers uh
more than 8.7 million of new jobs
created that is important new jobs
create there's not new jobs created you
shut down the economy for two years and
then you allowed it to reopen that's not
creating new jobs that's just taking off
the burden of shutting down the entire
economy says we're stronger do you
believe we're stronger economically than
we've ever been no you don't of course
not it's absurd and it shows you if they
had anything if they had anything at all
to run on they would run on it right now
it's just even one issue i don't know
healthcare uh immigration anything one
issue they would run on it and they
would try to blow that out of proportion
compared to everything else but they
don't so the only thing they can do is
just brazenly lie
that's
all they can do is brazenly lie
and and force you to go along with their
narrative
there are two components to human life
to bring it to a really 30 000 degree
view two components to the human person
will
and intellect what we want to do and
what we can force other people to do and
our intellect what we think is right
what we think is true what we think is
good and ideally your will and your
intellect are joined together
and then then you'll be practicing the
virtues
if
the libs had an argument they would
involve the intellect they would involve
reason they would involve argument they
don't have that though so it's pure will
they will force you to believe whatever
they say even if what they say
contradicts what they said an hour ago
that is the sign of a party that has
noth
no truth on its side
no goodness on its side it's just pure
force and they and they still have power
by the way and they will bring you into
line and they will bring macy gray into
line unless we take some of that power
back i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show